alter wenn ich sogar schon sehr wenn ich
sowas schon wer dann kriege ich hier
einfach ohne wird zu wenig so was schon
räder kriege ich auch einmal die krise
da muss ich das natürlich auch einfach
die dummheit muss man dann auch einfach
mal stoff hätte umso so kann man
dummheit heutzutage stoppen hey leute
und herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren minecraft 1.7.2010 von einem
zieht der euch am spot direkt ein
spanner ein npc village und eine wüste
pyramide in der wüste beschert und zwar
ist das hammer geil weil diese wüste
also erstmal der zieht hier warte wüste
doppelpunkt stoner noch wir haben noch
ein dorf und wir haben noch eine
pyramide so das sind die sachen die
darin vorkommen wir natürlich in den
kreativ modus sieht es 66 71 89 46 4 03
46 02 03 02 09 28 sowas da neue welt
erstellen dauert wieder ein kleines
moment an das geile ist halte sage ich
euch schonmal zwar das dorf liegt auf
eine erhöhung also wenn das hier so die
wüste ist ist hier sehr cool dass ich
das formal micro mache wenn ihr so die
wüste ist die kirche das dorf drauf als
warte hier ist meine hülle ich habe ihm
so eine coole lego hülle bei meinem
handy dies folgt wenn hier so die wüste
ist liegt hier das okay dass sie das
schon geladen gut dann zeige ich euch
das einfach direkt hier
er ist zirka hier so in dem bereich wir
haben auch so ein bisschen mond ist das
mo das ist ja dass mond das sind keine
rote rosen mehr schreibt nicht mehr die
kommentare
das ist mein moment da hinten haben
nämlich wieder ein paar biome
aneinandergrenzen wir haben nämlich und
wüste die normale da hinten haben wir
wie ihr links lädt eine ebene und hier
erstmal ein spannender sind zwar nicht
so wie alle geizen sachen drin wir
unglaublich hier eine kiste und jetzt
rangnick ist hier also hier die ganzen
sachen die kommen uns auf jeden fall
schon mal mit nem damit ihr nachher sein
kleines resultat daraus ziehen können
was er denn so alles haben also sind
jetzt die allerletzte sachen und das was
ist ein
zombies ponor so das war's auch schon
die wirklich direkt am spawn alles nur
direkt village wenn man sich da so hin
baut dazwischen ist man zwischen allen
drei sachen kann das super miteinander
verbinden
dann haben wir halt so sachen wie halt
so ganz normal so ist überzeugt fressen
und so also ich gehe jetzt mal davon aus
dass man dieses ziel wirklich am anfang
benutzt scheiße ich bin mit creative
immer alles direkt kaputt und die
witzige tatsache ist dass wenn die
willicher teilweise die gehen hier raus
und fallen dann einfach hier runter weil
die ihnen zugeordneten weg haben oder
was auch für witzig ist hier die aus der
aus der schmiede hier sind aber gar
keine wille das ist falsch
die aus der schmiede die gehen nie so
raus die gehen immer irgendwie so raus
und unfall die mal runter kriegen fall
schaden und dann laufen wieder hoch und
ihre schmiede irgendwie hier so laufen
wie dann irgendwie hoch gehen wieder da
rein und fallen wieder runter also das
beispiel hatte ich gerade das traurig
dass jetzt gerade keine gletscher hier
sind kirchen aber auch keine anfangs
sachen drin sein was zu essen denn ein
schwert und eine spitzhacke also ganz
normale sachen so viel anfangen so
hammer geil ich hab da gerade was gehört
ach das war offenbar nicht dachte da
stimmt doch manager also wir haben
wirklich sachen wie eine eiserne
vertrösten sind total den crazy stuff
eigentlich und hier drin sind drei
diamanten aber auch nicht so die alten
sachen halt wir haben hier wieder ganz
normal dass tnt tnt davon ahnen wir neun
stück dann haben wir hier die sache dann
haben wir hier die diamanten
dann haben wir hier nochmal die sachen
und die haben hier noch die sachen also
ich schäme mich mal ganz kurz wieder ins
dörflein damit ich euch hinter die
sachen zeige die ich so rausgeholt habe
also eigentlich sind neuen tnt
wer wir allgemein sonne so eine wüste
ich weiß garnicht alter okay das was ich
jetzt mal ebenfalls achtet mal links im
bild achtet mal links im bild das feld
gleich alles runter achters sandstein
ach das ist dann stein war das zu
langweilig wenn das jetzt nicht runter
fällt dem endstand das ist alles aus
sandstein die diese sachen sind aus
sandstein
aber da lässt sich jetzt alles aus
sandstein das doch langweilig für das
was runterfällt man früher war das
richtig geile sind die ganzen sachen
aber dafür etwas runter heute das
schwebt aber auch alles ist voll geil
na gut zurück zum thema und zwar dass
das ist die ausbeute ab das ist so die
aus wichtig ist immer wieder diese
errungenschaft ich öfters inventar 1000
mal pro folge und ich kriege immer
wieder den neuerungen geschäft
wahrscheinlich dass pro welt immer so
das ist die ganze sache nie mehr raus
geht also für ein anfang innerhalb von
drei minuten kriegt ihr diese ganzen
sachen und das ist schon mal haben wir
von anfang ein bisschen so spitzhacke
beste frames in unserer ganzen stadt vor
allem fünf weisen ist auch ganz gut drei
diamanten ist allgemein sehr gut
und hier ist es halt auch sehr witzig
wartet da das sind doch villiger hier
sind village oh warte kriegt jetzt fall
schaden guckt er hat da da da da da
sehen wir es diese villiger sind so
gottes verdammt um die gehen dahin jetzt
läuft der eine hier nämlich wieder hoch
und drängelt wieder einen anderen runter
bzw drängelt sich selbst darunter
und da ist der nächste und die kriegen
immer wieder fall schaden und das kommt
der nächste gast der nächste also die
sind so blöd ich meine ich bin zwar
selbst will ich aber bin ich so blöd und
je nach da oben und fall darunter sind
die behindert die sind alle behindert in
dem kopf guckt euch das an die fallen
einfach alle runter also das war das was
ich wohl meinte und jetzt sind hier auch
manager alter wenn ich sowas schon sehr
wenn ich sowas schon wer dann kriege ich
hier einfach das ohne witz wenn ich
sowas schon mehrer kriege ich auch
einmal die krise da muss ich das
natürlich auch einfach die dummheit muss
man dann auch einfach mal stoff
nur so kann man dummheit heutzutage
stoppen doch ist das nur noch heutzutage
möglich
na gut freunde ich würde sagen es euch
gefallen hat und die musik vorstellen
wollte danach smash den button nach oben
community ich liebe euch alle und wir
sind beim nächsten mal wieder